hi it's time now for this week in
history
[Music]
it's some kind of show where four people
are on it and they really like each
other they don't like me but i like them
a lot
that is amazing that was our very first
interview with bob saget as host of the
morning program on cbs it actually
premiered 35 years ago this week now it
only lasted nine months but it all
worked out for bob because he used those
skills to play a fake morning show host
on full house and of course e.t was
there from the very beginning
[Music]
it's a story of a guy named danny
who was married with three girls of his
own and he had two friends just like
their mother the youngest one in curls
here's the story of a guy named tanner
i'm sorry i set you up is there a
therapist here he told me not to look at
the camera
can i start again
that was so painful bob was always the
comedian even from our very first visit
with him on the full house set in 1987
and while he wasn't in the original
unaired pilot with the rest of the cast
he fully embraced the role of danny
tanner and became the tv dad to a
generation of fans a lot of parents tell
me this is not a show i'm afraid for my
children to watch because it has a
lesson and nobody's getting hurt and the
women do have some clothing on which is
one of my problems with the show i think
everyone should be in the nude except
for the children they should be dressed
now
oh man that'll never get on how you guys
doing
take care
they love me they can't come up with me
the other public goes after me we spent
a lot of time with bob throughout the
show's eighth season run from on
location shoots to behind the scenes set
tours this is a freak thing in the
living room
no one plays the organ lurch does not
live here i don't know what it's doing
here
but what always stood out to us was his
love for his tv family we have twins
that play the babies and they're just
amazing you really are a good sport
candice cameron that plays the oldest
daughter is just a really good actress i
mean she's made me cry several times and
that's during comedic scenes
hey
what are you up to steph jody sweetin is
she's like a little i don't know she's
like george burns she has great natural
comic delivery this is how i brainwash
the children on the show i make them
listen to my special music oh my gosh
it's a candy cane toothbrush
et's last time on the full house set was
in 1994 for a christmas episode
[Music]
just five months later the cast was
caught off guard when abc abruptly
canceled the show i like acting so i'm
going to do more of it and i might do
another series or i like directing
though
so i'm very confused i don't know
whether to go to lunch in the bathroom
still over the years the full house
family remained close they first
reunited in 1997 to surprise bob while
he hosted america's funniest home videos
man you guys look older what and in 2004
the crew rallied around mary kate and
ashley olson at the premiere of their
movie new york minute how much fun to
see everybody i love everybody but we we
see each other so it's like we'd rather
not do it in public we just look like
cousins or something you know you just
want to see him hold him
then almost 30 years since the first
episode fuller house hit netflix hey
tommy
fuller house came back because it's
demos i mean he fought and i said yeah
i'll do that we didn't really hang out
much in the old days and then now we
become best friends but right we
literally
are brothers the reboot lasted five
seasons we were on set for the emotional
final day of shooting there was a moment
where
we were hugging because that's what you
do at fuller house
and um there were tears but then we just
kept crying and we didn't let go of each
other for about five minutes bob cries a
lot and he wears his his emotions on the
surface he's one of the most sensitive
people i know we love each other we've
been through
marriages and and divorces and births
and deaths and we've been friends all
these years
and we've been there for each other and
people have heard all this ad nauseam
but it's
it's honestly true here we go
before we go one of bob saget's many
passions in life aside from comedy was
charity work specifically with the
scleroderma research foundation indeed
bob lost his sister gay to the
autoimmune disease in 1994 and fans are
being encouraged to make a donation in
bob's name today you know all of us take
solace in knowing that he is reunited
with his family once again and we're
going to leave you with bob's words on
this very important cause good night
everybody take care y'all i have a
sister that passed away
and she's and she died from this disease
scleroderma tragically bob died on what
would have been his sister gay's 75th
birthday in the years following her
passing bob enlisted many of his famous
friends to raise more than 25 million
dollars to help find a cure
it's a horrible disease and a lot of
people have it it's as prevalent as ms
or md and you're disfigured and your or
your internal organs can
totally deteriorate
my sister passed away from scleroderma
and dave's sister passed away from
cancer and then john's sister had a mild
problem with the ms and she recovered
when you go through all these life
things with people and it does bring you
closer to people
[Music]